so here's the first story we got from
newsweek trump urges death penalty for
drug dealers quote china has no drug
problem
they say trump made the remarks in a
speech he delivered in vegas las vegas
nevada friday during a rally for his
endorsed candidates in the state's
gubernatorial and senate races the
speech was marked by two recurring
themes for trump a demand for law and
order as well as an admiration for
heavy-handed governance he said quote if
you look at countries all throughout the
world the only ones that don't have a
drug problem are those that institute
the death penalty for drug dealers
they're the only ones you understand
that china has no drug problem during a
speech trump recalled asking chinese
president xi jinping if his country had
a drug problem quote i innocently and
perhaps naively asked if there was much
of a drug problem in china why would you
ask he didn't say this but i'm saying
what he was thinking why would you have
such a dumb question is that no no no we
don't have a drug problem why would we
have a drug problem there is no problem
drug dealers get the death penalty the
trial goes very quickly so instead of
coming to chu into china they go
someplace else we've had big drug
problems over the centuries but we don't
have a drug problem at all now they
don't deal in china the former president
said so matt you were you're actually
there right so so he said he gave us
similar remarks just today oh okay um
i got the old version of the story yeah
america
first
agenda conference put on by america
first policy institute which i run i'm
co-chair of their center for law and
justice and yes i this is not he's he
said this actually while he was
president as well this is a theme uh
that i've heard from donald trump many
times
and
you know
i think his his sentiment
is
spot on if you look at uh the opioid uh
you know fentanyl drug overdose crisis
in our country we we're we're losing
over a hundred thousand people a year
now in our country
uh two overdoses yeah in fact um
you know more people
die of uh it's the number one killer uh
from the for 18 to 45. but these are
prescribed aren't they not fentanyl no
no so the the prescription opioids are a
much smaller segment now what's what's
actually happening
is um you know people are
that
you you've my understanding and again
i'm not a drug user not a drug dealer
have never used an illegal drug um
and so
uh my understanding and talking to the
experts and talking to people is is that
it you build up a tolerance to opioids
and fentanyl is an opioid it's a
synthetic opioid and so if you don't um
if you don't either don't take it it's
laced in something else you take or if
you you know take too much of it that it
can just you know pretty much
wipe you out now this is not you know
we also thought about at the department
of justice you know we reinstituted the
death penalty
um
because it had been a moratorium since
the bush administration on the death
penalty and one of the things we thought
about was using fentanyl
as as the lethal agent
um wow in order to demonstrate kind of
the lethality is that a word yes yes
um i'm sure people watching are gonna
you know
get in uh an inner comment to tell me if
it is there isn't but no it is only you
can see that um
but you know the to to demonstrate just
how potent fentanyl can be but uh so
what does it do like when you when you
overdose on fentanyl you kind of pass
out is that what happens
yeah essentially it it
my understanding is it takes your you
know your vitals down to zero i mean you
just kind of like it
depresses your you know your your pull
your heart and your lungs and you stop
breathing and you you know essentially
sounds i mean in terms of the death
penalty that sounds humane at the very
least
yeah and it's pretty much what we're
doing with an another cocktail of drugs
and we you know we um i'll give you an
example i mean i know you don't want to
do a show about the death penalty and so
uh i i want to keep this it should be
lighter because i'm usually a fun person
but it's just so dark yeah it's really
dark and i'm not a dark person i'm an
optimist but you know we um
in the state of iowa my home state i was
the u.s attorney in the southern
district of iowa there's a northern
district which i actually have if you
have a southern district that implies a
northern district but in the northern
district of iowa we had had a drug
dealer um who
executed uh a a family of five
and uh including the mom dad and and the
kids and so that he was sentenced
rightfully to the death penalty and then
has been had been sitting
um in prison for over 20 years um
because there was this de facto
moratorium even though congress had said
and the president signed a law saying
there is a death penalty in in federal
system for certain things you know they
weren't they weren't doing it and you
know the bite administration is now not
doing it either but he this gentleman
from iowa
um
was
you know put to death under the federal
system in the trump administration and
it was um i knew a prosecutor who had
done that case and had been around for
20 years waiting to see that and he
actually called me that day and and and
thanked me and thanked the
administration for you know finally
giving that family that was still alive
you know justice but so so going to
trump's comments and just to clarify
the article actually the article that i
had sourced because we had a couple of
them and i made this mistake was that
trump said this more than once he said
it a couple weeks ago and he said it
again we have a story here from three
hours ago trump calls for a quick death
penalty for drug dealers this one is
actually the headline is more overt
and so uh
in his first speech back in washington
since he left the presidency he called
for a quick death i don't know that
feels a little heavy-handed right a drug
dealer like to what degree are we
talking about yeah well i mean i'm not
going to try to morally um justify a
certain levels of drug dealing and
compare and contrast that to others
if you know anything about drug dealing
it's always a pyramid scheme right you
have the the street level drug dealers
that are you know usually the ones that
are taken out and then you have
different levels and oftentimes in my
experience about two steps two hops get
you to a mexican drug cartel um and so
uh if you're talking about kingpins we
already have kingpin statutes uh they
don't call for the death penalty my
understanding and again i don't i'm not
the trump whisperer i've spent a lot of
time with him i heard his remarks today
my belief is that he really
wants to target the head of the snake
the kingpins uh the ones that are
getting rich and uh you know kind of the
pablo escobar types
not the street level hustler
not that they're not any more
less morally responsible for this
scourge of
you know of illicit drugs in our system
you know we need to have a bigger
conversation also
congress has been completely
unavailable and uninvolved in you know
the regulation of drugs
you know we the states have taken it on
uh and you know mostly deregulated uh
marijuana for example i don't you know
this is again this isn't the topic that
we're talking about but i have a lot of
strong feelings on this
and um
you know i the federal government
is needs to do one of two things
either join the states or most of the
states and have congress you know pass a
law that that reclassifies marijuana or
start enforcing the law what we can't
have is these laws that aren't enforced
that you know because it's because you
know what we need and the rule of law
for it to work is certainty uh for
citizens i think it should be i think
chipotle but um i think you get bigger
challenges when you get into harder
stuff fentanyl especially is getting
laced into all these drugs
and then you know to be honest uh i
oppose that i oppose a death penalty
because
you know
the best example i can give to people is
kamala harris deciding who gets to die
doesn't sound good to me at all i
understand that there are really bad
people like the guy you mentioned right
so tim let's let's
let me just
the way
the death penalty works is the jury that
the peers the 12 people that decide
whether the person's guilty or not
decide the penalty phase and whether or
not they have the death penalty so so to
seek the death penalty that's about the
only thing that actually the attorney
general united states can do and only
can do everything else has been can or
has been delegated in the department of
justice but but the one thing that the
attorney general has to do is determine
whether or not to seek the death penalty
um you know in these cases and we did we
spent a lot of time i mean you i i
that is the most um
difficult
decision uh that a attorney general i
think has to make is whether or not to
seek
um
the death penalty and you know you get
these recommendations from the u.s
attorney's office all over the country
some are you know less uh likely to
pursue the death penalty some are more
likely to pursue the death penalty but
it's just the the cases are just
the worst of the worst i mean you know
it's it's it's you're just like oh my
god i mean this can't you know this fact
pattern is the worst i've ever seen then
you read the next one it's like oh my
goodness and this is this is even more
horrible the challenge is
look you know you you hear a story you
read
the the details about it and you're like
this person
you know can't be rehabilitated they're
truly a violent sociopath but proven
beyond a reasonable doubt i don't know
if i trust the state to get it right and
then the issue is you know to quote
benjamin franklin is better than 100
guilty persons escaped than one innocent
person suffer the idea to me that the
state would say look we believe these
facts to be true to the best of our
abilities and you might have uh good
people who are like this guy did brutal
things to a family and we we can't have
this remain that i totally get and
saying you know so we're going to this
person has forfeit their life by taking
the lives of others the issue i guess is
just that
there's a percentage of people who are
innocent who are going to be killed by
the state and
i don't know man i'm not gonna pretend
to have the answers but i can just tell
you i just don't like the idea yeah i
mean obviously
the system has built in tremendous
safeguards uh at least in the federal
system like you know there's some states
and throughout american history i think
you know that the safeguards weren't
there but as you know and i'm talking
about you know my experience is in
federal court and in federal law and you
know as it relates to the death penalty
the federal death penalty and there are
um
there are a lot of safeguards built in
but you know i do share that that it
would you know obviously we'd rather uh
you know have a hundred people have life
in prison
than have one you know person get the
death penalty that and have be executed
that you know was innocent yeah let me
so you know it's a tough area but i know
this we're not yes mary is the purpose
of the death penalty then
to
seek retribution for victims
and
enact justice or is it simply by
necessity to remove this person from
society and any chance that they could
escape prison because at this point
we're releasing so many criminals
i'm not sure where i stand on it
yeah i mean there's a lot of reasons we
have uh you know criminal prosecution
and criminal punishment you know
retribution is one reason punishment is
another reason uh you know excluding the
the death penalty rehabilitation um is
another reason that you know we have uh
criminal penalties
you know so
i've spent i'm not in the legislature i
was never in the legislature and so you
know my kind of i haven't done the
balancing test on on on this as to you
know sort of where but congress has
passed a law that says there is a
certain
category of crimes that is that is
eligible for the death penalty and
here's the process and so um you know as
a as a prosecutor and as of the former
you know acting attorney general we we
executed the laws
i didn't have i didn't have to decide
and i don't think it's appropriate
actually that's why these moratoriums
i think take you know the the people
through their representatives have
passed this law you your representatives
the people you voted for have passed
this law or have not repealed it more
importantly and so you know let's put
that on the ballot let's make that an
issue let's look that you know if the
people don't want the death penalty more
tim to your point is let you know let's
let's vote for it that's what i never
understand
and this is what the left loves to do is
they love to have the executive branch
under their under their you know leaders
like joe biden
um
you know decide that certain things
aren't you know morally reprehensible
but they'll never take the vote because
you know that mostly the american people
are on it are in a different place on it
republicans don't seem to do anything
about it i mean yeah i mean that's 2016
through 18 and they just let russia gate
happen
they did um you know i was i got there
in october of 2017 and uh you know not a
day went by that somehow the russian
collusion fable didn't affect you know
the department of justice because it was
if you remember
people you want to forget because it was
such a
a negative uh you know just
bs i know i can't say what i want to say
but it was such because
ultimately every night it was just some
new revelation some leaker had said you
know some
fbi agent or sources or you know it's
just it's just this constant drumbeat of
stories that in retrospect were all fake
news yep and so you can totally when you
know donald trump says you know and
points to the back of the room and says
you guys are fake news i mean they are
they are thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you